so
here was a comforting and healthy slow
cooker recipe i love slow cooker recipes
i love her abby sharp is with us
so slow cooking is healthy why well i
think
i love slow cooking slow cooker recipes
because they allow you to
use lean inexpensive ingredients like
tougher cuts of meat and those types of
things and they soften them and they
soften them up yeah
delicious and tender with very little
added fat very good and we like hearing
that so yeah
she's making this get this quinoa
stuffed cabbage rolls yes
that's great so what what would we
normally stuff our cabbage rolls with
rice
usually it's rice and other kind of
ground beef okay so where do we begin
well and we're gonna add lots of veggies
to get started okay
i've got some diced onion here so that's
kind of
just to get some flavor in there a
little bit of
garlic just your classic this is
not traditional but this is what i like
a little grated carrot because
what you will see in a lot of cabbage
roll recipes is sometimes like sugar or
a little bit of sweet element
sometimes dried fruit but we've got some
natural sweetness going on with some
carrot yeah add some more veggies in the
mix why not
and my quinoa right right so yes
traditionally you'll see the rice but
quinoa is very high in protein
fiber gluten free too if that's a
consideration for you
about a cup of that smoked paprika very
common in eastern european
cuisine a little bit of our egg that's
our classic binder yeah and i'm using a
combo
beef turkey i use the extra lean because
like we were saying
it really tenderizes it you don't need
to worry about these being
dry when they come out and my secret
ingredients you'll see here you're like
what is that secreting
secret ingredient you've seen me do this
with my burgers before yeah but i've got
some ground up mushrooms because
mushrooms have the same meaty flavor and
texture
as ground beef yeah so you know you can
actually what kind of mushrooms are you
talking about i use cremini but really
any kind works because you're grinding
them up really
you don't see what kind of and you're
getting rid of the water when you're
doing that too a little bit because yeah
i like to squeeze them out a little bit
so they're not so so watery but you know
what they also keep these really really
moist
so it's it's doing double duty in all
sorts of ways makes these lower in
calories
and you can get more at more cabbage
rolls out of the recipe
very good so we're just gonna season
this up with a little bit of
salt and pepper and just do that right
there
i'm going to get the cabbage so
basically what i've done
is i have removed you want to remove the
cabbage from the head
i've taken out you can see a little the
stem because it tends to be very
tough it's tough and you want to make
sure that these guys are pliable
right so that you can roll them up
really a little bit of boiling water for
how long
oh it doesn't take lot much just like 30
seconds or so you just want to make them
a little bit more
easy to maneuver right right get this
all mixed up
okay and i am using
a measuring cup for this because i don't
know about you but whenever i
do anything eyeballing do you over stuff
i over stuff yeah i
i admit it full confession here okay
because the first one will turn out
really good yeah the second
one you know by the end of the batch
you're making
really fat cabbage rolls someone's going
to fight over who gets the big one who
gets the small one
you don't need that dinner time drama
you know it's so funny when my
aunt used to make cabbage rolls or my
mother would make stuffed peppers
yeah i would take just this part and not
eat the cabbage
or a pepper because i thought it was
weird
using it as a dish you know i thought it
was weird wrapping it in cabbage but now
i understand now you understand right
okay so let's do this let's do
one of these guys yep one of these in
yeah pop it in
just like that and the the i like the uh
this is the operation so you go roll
tuck
roll just like that pop those into the
slow cooker we've got some already in
here and how long does that stay they do
for all day or half day you can do it
all day so
if you are in a rush you could have four
to five hours on high but
typically you're away all day at work so
you go eight to nine hours on low but we
have to do tomato sauce you gotta have
something attached
yeah for them to bathe in all day long
to get nice and tender
so this is just some basic low sodium
low sugar
uh pasta sauce whatever your family has
on hand how low should that sugar be
when you're buying pasta sauce i always
basically look for the
i mean tomatoes have natural sugar right
and we can't escape that yeah is there a
number though because i was looking at
the other day
well what i would pay more attention to
is the ingredient list
and look for is there added sugar to
this if not how about tomato first
tomato should be the first thing you
know that's what you're looking for
but i looked at the sugar content and
even though some of the living's
beautiful and everything i couldn't
believe how high
yes some of the sugar was yeah
absolutely okay so we've got some
more smoked paprika yes very traditional
i'm gonna get some
a touch of honey because like i said you
know a lot of these cabbage roll recipes
have
a little bit of sweetness but i've
really cut down the amount of
sugar um in this recipe just a teeny
little tablespoon a teaspoon or so all
right two shakes of worcestershire
whatever you want to say nobody actually
knows how to say that not really
you got it so this is my other kind of
special ingredient
sauerkraut not just for sandwiches
anymore right because
this adds that kind of sweet and sour
balance sure but it tends to be very
high in sodium so
i've rinsed this sauerkraut squeezed it
out so i'm not adding extra water here
and you're basically just rinsing away
all the salt like a lot of that salt
there
very so let's go get this so this recipe
that you made for us today abby how many
would uh
cabbage rolls would it be about 16 16
yards you come home the house smells
good so good just carefully ladle this
on we don't want to
i wouldn't pour this on because we've
got cute outfits on them raw clean only
we don't need any
tomatoes tomato sauce splattering yeah
but pop the lid on like i said eight to
nine hours you've got a delicious
healthy meal ready to go it's very
balanced you've got your lean meat
you've got your whole grains veggies in
there
to prep it or anything before you put it
in with any kind of uh
no i mean a lot of these slow cookers
are nonstick right okay very good
they're good to go okay thanks to abby
great recipe take a look at this this is
a beauty isn't it everyone's gonna go
home with a slow cooker for black and
decorated
when we catch up with the men of bitten
stay tuned